[Music]
and slap on the wrist me submitted by
New Zealand does exist who the [ __ ] said
it did it yeah I'm not an easy man yeah
you [ __ ] shot Lord of the Rings there
bro come on now I like New Zealand Kiwis
are the [ __ ] I did hear that thing
they're playing the internet saying that
yesterday that doesn't exist me that's
what they're going how can i Australian
I system said hot asian women on their
New Zealand makes me think of Hawaii and
Australia really had a big baby okay
a med student who stabbed her boyfriend
cut everybody spam it up could be spared
jail because of her extraordinary talent
why what how do you get into med school
because he that takes a lot of
commitment and discipline they usually
level-headed and how does a person like
that go around stabbing people
maybe she sad them with really surgical
precision and they're like this is
talented or maybe she's for real for
stabbing or the girl is Korean or
remember that uber chick the the doctor
uber chick that was flipping out ahead
drivers that Union won yeah she flipped
out she was like go ahead
oh she's Indian right yeah Korean or
Indian this girl neither I knew it yeah
so did somebody happen and say ah you
too smart to go to jail what is her
extraordinary talent decides i but i
think it is what do you think it is
[ __ ] dick yeah you know at the same
time he opened his mouth so Lavina I
could go to a hospital
levena she's a 24 year old Oxford
University Oxford
oh [ __ ] amen to the dictionary do you
today
yeah so apparently she stabbed her
Cambridge educated boyfriend Henry John
they're both smart yes in the leg oh
shut on leg die see if it's not above
the body it's all good
none if you mean super hip way do get
like a pen
sewing with me or what happened so
really they got they were drinking
oh thanks some sort of drugs oh no they
call it a drinking drug steals argument
so they were arguing a lot and then
that's when Lavina punched him Oh wife
that's a victim with a bread knife
nothing there oh my god that's just a
normal argument a bread knife
wait so and I love you so ridiculous oh
no dude that's not normal that affecting
the classical spatula the Harold come on
you can't report that to the cops
you're so lame at stake with the bread
bag stove or you can yeah see I don't
know [ __ ] so he stabbed him and then
hurls a laptop a glass and a jam jar
dude straight up at that point jam jar
and she's one when she threw the laptop
at me that's what I'm throwing my imac
at her like straight up is gonna happen
there's no way there's no way after you
[ __ ] swipe at me I'm like I you was a
crazy baby imma let that go then she
throws a glass I'm like eh that's not
cool then she throws her laptop I'm like
that [ __ ] great I am Chuck you my
back at the [ __ ] you have to you know
what I will do I will start hitting the
floor the [ __ ] pile of popups on the
[ __ ] I'll I'll cook you a superhero
like a donkey [ __ ] laughter Allah do I
want to see this thrown [ __ ] pile and
then just start in their face like you
beat your girlfriend no I just [ __ ]
threw Kyle Leatherface Donkey Kong
Durell yes we have you gone [ __ ] by a
jam dress no I'm just saying it's the
worst thing because it's the heaviest
thing out of all those options we'll get
it cast landed jobs are in the face
that's the worst one
maybe the laptop I think it's the laptop
no but I think the jam jar can break and
cut your fish it's a full jar of jam -
it's the heaviest one - it could break
your bones
oh my god we sit down with a welt on my
head [ __ ] eating a snack of [ __ ]
that's all bad
[Music]
it's like a [ __ ] delicious grenade no
thank you my wife catches a mountain
about all your deep he's also the guy I
want to do this yeah so she got charged
with unlawful wounding at the horse what
a wound where and so the judge said that
normally the offense would mean a
custodial sentence I'm not sure what
that means not clean up the streets no
oh maybe a community service is what you
get isn't that isn't that a salt oh
she's just meant to charge with were
thing yeah I'm guessing cause are
definitely I kind of like it yeah so
this is a little bit of fun just a
little bit of fire I just google it says
can mandatory custody of the conduct
either in prison or in some other
classic uh jail if you're going to jail
or like home what is it about that that
one gotcha anyways she's better normally
we met but he deferred the sentencing
for a period of four months and pretty
much like in today she wouldn't be
jailed because of her extraordinary
talent in medicine so this girl uh tree
cancer is gonna do society some good
she's just that bright um no she's not
because she's even had articles
published in medical journals and she
before she's even graduated Wow just to
let you know girl you're never gonna get
dick again cuz nobody wants to stick
their dick in crazy unless she's hot
everyone was a stick to the case just
like never mind she she might have a
chance
god damn it she's classy pretty yeah
she's classy pretty and she's a doctor
yep she's gonna get lots of dicks like
she the freak in the sheets but a lady
on the street she looks like she likes
to play with magic wand it is [ __ ]
pretending to read a book
come on Val you sick [ __ ] sighs got
published articles see nothing that's a
fake pretend to read a book told I do
that all the time what what makes it a
real reading first of all she the books
not even open
in the back nobody reads to Matt come on
I always read the best oxygen too bad a
lot of people read the back I also want
to see that's not fair you always see
all these like level-headed pictures I
want to see her in the midst of swiping
throwing a laptop let's see her in her
element yeah I want to see what that
looks like
Nancy I agree with the judge if she's
that [ __ ] smart and she's going to
solve the world's problems she could do
whatever but she's emotionally bought if
she's stabbing her boyfriend on the knee
with a butter knife by the way not a
machete bread knife that's fine how many
times right not in a song is a bread
knife it's got the little ridges dude
it's fine what are the ridges meant to
do the cut [ __ ] bread so it doesn't
smash it yeah Madison with a kid - who
is butter flesh I think I think she's a
okay with me I think this guy right here
she's not a psychopath she's just a
normal college girl did she get hit - no
oh like physically not that I know
[ __ ] stuff because she just sounds
like a normal Korean go to me yeah I
think I'm gonna throw up cuz she's white
it was a Korean girl she actually did a
pretty good job she controlled herself
yeah
Cree gonna [ __ ] crazy dude I'm gonna
I've never thrown anything in my life in
an argument really yeah that's because
you're very civilized
no what is the worst that you've done by
in terms of physicality in - no I tend
to myself I'll punch like walls of the
floor I'll [ __ ] smash my phone oh
you're an angry individual you need to
go to an event mMmmm that's crazy G oh
I've seen a Mariel strike something once
and I should scare the [ __ ] out of me
and it was what did she do with the
console of my Jeep and then she just
goes well I wanted her to express her
emotions and when she did I unlocked
Pandora's box the financier means when
he gets mad and he's driving
it's the [ __ ] so I think this [ __ ]
could be holding on to the steering
wheel you go like this he that's laws
but then the music sauce but he fell 50
[ __ ] please hitting all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] he just [ __ ] me and I might try
not to laugh but I'm like did this to
these massive you know on the car looks
really small - what could turn it off
when he does this is their homes in the
ocean - dude that's the case even Angels
Austria I love to actually laugh in his
face on the pitch and I'm on the brakes
- I slam on the brakes or if she's
driving then I just grabbed the car then
you hear the car much like I need focus
like where I don't give a [ __ ] up on the
freeway
we're gonna pass the [ __ ] out right now
I'm dangerous Marielle doesn't laugh she
just goes like this because I'm mad I
don't like that everybody does easy [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
yeah so this the judge candidate thing
that this seems to me that this was a
one-off it completely not a one-off that
is great she's hi lots of other exactly
you are she comes from a powerful family
that gave the judge some moolah thinking
that I think that did exactly well water
that is not a one-off a one-off is like
butter knife swipe why did my kin Elaine
no she went swipe right yeah laptop
toast
papaya scrambled eggs bacon cook up a
waffle let it cool a little bit pigs it
up like real the real question was what
was the crime unlawful and when do
something like what what caused her to
be like that that's the real question
also like when she found out you've been
[ __ ] 50 girls behind my back and if
she got crazy yeah she came she came
home and she was there in the midst of
eating [ __ ] and she was drunk from a
party and she's like wow I can't believe
you're doing this to me and then like
she starts throwing [ __ ] and of all
things a girl from Cornell
I'm saying girl from corn out you what
eat [ __ ] of a Cornell woman my god how
dare you tell me like what really made
her snap is when the boyfriend said he
was going to call her mom yeah there was
no harm on I'm gonna kill eyes once they
were like fighting I'm gonna tell you no
I'm into a tight family yep don't tell
my mama Nate well so let me consider the
quote for noises he says to prevent this
extraordinarily able young lady from not
following her long-held desire to enter
the profession she wishes to would be a
sentence which would be too severe
that's why she's not going to jail but
they are why it's [ __ ] how the
honorees write about [ __ ] kind of they
are saying that is very unlikely she'll
ever become a surgeon because of her
criminal conviction just to be disclosed
also much you're going to be there like
a pediatrician what an idiot is that
what means a butter knife I bet you
there's his dick is hard then they're
supposed to get up he's like ten do it
finish this court session sitting down I
have a stomachache and he just stopped
calling out yeah or any from a violent
girl you don't stick your dick increases
hey guys hope you enjoyed that episode
please don't miss a beat and subscribe
if you don't subscribe you don't know
when a new video is uploaded but for
more videos click up here